hey schön dass ihr dabei seid zdf heute
live nachdem die korona zahlen in den
letzten wochen ja so dramatisch
gestiegen sind und von der
geschäftsführenden regierung aber auch
von der zukünftigen regierung wenig
zunächst kam passiert jetzt was heute
hat der bundesrat den corona änderungen
im koma gesetzt was die zukünftige wohl
zukünftige ampel regierung vorgelegt hat
die man der bundesrat zugestimmt heute
auch außerdem gestern war bund länder
treffen und dort hat man sich auch auf
neue corona maßnahmen geeinigt und eine
darunter war das nun also ein angebot
gemacht werden soll für alle über 18 für
eine auffrischimpfung einen sogenannten
booster deren impfung fünf bis sechs
monate zurückliegt das bedeutet aber
dass da jetzt tatsächlich millionen von
menschen also jetzt zu ihrer
auffrischimpfung gehen werden und wir
stellen die frage wie das zu schaffen
sein soll und wenn ihr fragen oder
kommentare dazu habt dann stellt die
gerne in den stream oder fragt direkt
per mail nach und wir haben jetzt die
möglichkeit zu sprechen mit dort ferber
sie steht für uns in bochum dort hat
nämlich das impfzentrum tatsächlich
wieder auf und zwar seit gestern schönen
guten abend dort ferber
ja hallo ich bin hier in der bochumer
innenstadt hier zur einen seite ist der
weihnachtsmarkt und direkt an der
anderen seite ist das impfzentrum und
hier gibts ne riesen schlange davor
dieses im zentrum hat seit gestern
geöffnet du hast es gesagt und ich habe
ja auch gleich schon leute getroffen die
hier heute waren wenn sie mir fragen wie
sehr sind gerade geben worden
bloß hat ja die dritte impfung wie lange
haben sie gewartet zwei stunden von drei
uhr an bis zum ja eigentlich zweieinhalb
stunden bis 6
älter als die aufregend dankeschön ich
bin 82 jahre alt und mein partner ist 85
jahre alt und wir haben uns aufgemacht
wir waren gestern schon hier aber da war
gar kein durchkommen dann waren wir um
14 03 uhr waren drei uhr punkt drei uhr
eigentlich weil es hat geheißen das
erste die impfung schon am also
von 15
bis 21 uhr sein sollte aber dann war das
erst um 17 uhr und dann war das für uns
zu spät dann sind wir aber heute wieder
bekommen
rechtzeitig um 15 uhr und sind jetzt
geimpft worden gerade alles sehr nette
lief alles fließend ab kann man nicht
anders sagen aber es ist sehr schlecht
organisiert wirklich wenn sie hier heute
dran kommen wollen also um 6 waren
glaube ich schon keine termine mehr dar
und sind sie fit aber ich weiß nicht
ihre freunde haben die sich als auch
ihrem alter hierher zu kommen ja wir
sind immer zugegangen wäre ich habe auch
einige getroffen die sich nicht impfen
lassen wollen aber ist fast chancenlos
wenn die überzeugt sind sich nicht
impfen zu lassen ist das sehr sehr
schwer aber wir wand von anfang an
entschlossen die also die dritte impfung
summen sind wir sehen's vielen dank ja
also wir sehen uns der andrang ist hier
wirklich sehr sehr groß und jemand der
mir erzählen kann wie das insgesamt ist
das ist der herr springer thomas
sprenger sprecher der stadt bochum der
springer gestern hat dieses zentrum
eröffnet wie ist das bis sagen wie viele
impfungen haben sie für impfen können
wie ist der andrang also im zentrum ist
etwas hochgegriffen das ist eine
impfstelle das heißt hier ist ein arzt
und mitarbeiter der impft aber sie sehen
das ja das angebot war riesig
nachgefragt also die schlange war
gestern auch schon sehr sehr lange wir
schaffen in der zeit zwischen 17 und 21
uhr ungefähr 100 impfungen zu geben
haben sozusagen heute auch noch mal
wieder ein bisschen auf gestoppt weil
das angebot einfach so stark nachgefragt
wird die menschen wollen geimpft werden
die allermeisten sind ja immer gewusst
hat zu werden aber es gibt natürlich
auch welche gott sei dank die sich erst
im finalen wollen wenn die leute hier
hinkommen brauchen die irgendwelche
voraussetzungen müssen das bochumer sein
oder wer darf sich bei ihnen impfen das
also zunächst einmal muss man sagen
grundsätzlich sind ja die ärztinnen und
ärzte die niedergelassenen ärztinnen und
ärzte
angesprochen die impfung durchzuführen
aber wir bekommen immer wieder die
rückmeldung dass die wartezeit nicht
allzu lang sind also die ärzte schaffen
es wohl nicht ganz allein deshalb
springen wir einen deshalb schaffen wir
diese stellen wir haben mehrere eben
auch im stadtgebiet die wir auch in der
nächsten woche noch weiter öffnen werden
man kann hier hinkommen beziehungsweise
ab der nächsten woche werden wir auch
ein termin system wieder einführen weil
es einfach an das organisatorisch gar
nicht handle
preis.de anfang auch wenn ich nicht aus
bochum komme darf ich aber auch zu ihnen
kommen ja ich denke aber in jeder stadt
gibt es diese angebote wie wir sie auch
haben insofern denke ich werde in jeder
stadt natürlich auch geimpft und das
sollten die menschen natürlich dann auch
dort wahrnehmen wo sie herkommen
was bedeutet der aufbau dieser
impfstelle für sie eigentlich
logistischen sie das entschieden dass es
eigentlich im stein geben wird die
impfzentren die es im ganzen land gab
wurden ende september geschlossen wir
hatten auch schon frühzeitig darauf
hingewiesen dass das ein fehler ist wir
wollten dass diese impfzentren auf plan
weil wir wussten der andrang ist groß
die nachfrage ist groß und über kurz
oder lang wird es diese booster
empfehlung geben und dann werden die
menschen auch wieder geimpft werden
sollen wir haben dann natürlich die
impfzentren schließen müssen wie wir
alle anderen städte auch haben aber dann
trotzdem eine mobile ein mobiles angebot
gehabt immer wieder im stadtgebiet
verteilt haben wir immer angebote
gemacht insofern stand die logistik und
wir haben sie natürlich auch weiter
aufrechterhalten aber so was wie hier
das ist sozusagen eine hauruckaktion
schon aus der letzten woche gewesen weil
wir gesehen haben zu beginn des
weihnachtsmarktes oder mit beginn des
weihnachtsmarktes war einfach der
andrang und die nachfrage groß und
gestern hat ja auch die stiko die
booster impfung für alle ab 18 empfohlen
und völlig klar das hat noch mal den
anderen auch sehr sehr deutlich
verstärkt dort wir haben es mehr und
gehört dort wir haben es gesehen und
gehört in eine wahnsinns eindrangen
wiederum darf ich kurz dazwischen ich
wollte mal fragen ist das denn jetzt in
bochum ist das ein einzelfall wie sieht
sonst aus in nrw ist das gibt's mehr
impfzentren die da jetzt schon auf haben
also diese impfstellen die gibt es
durchaus die haben an verschiedenen
städten und verschiedenen orten geöffnet
ähnlich wie in bochum übrigens einige
die durchgehend offen waren andere die
jetzt wieder eröffnet worden sind es
gibt vereinzelt sogar impfzentren ich
weiß es in ennepetal zum beispiel ist
ein impfzentrum das regelhaft
geschlossen war jetzt wieder eröffnet
worden es bleibt aber dabei dass man
diese im zentrums struktur nicht
aufbauen möchte da sagt der
nordrhein-westfälische
gesundheitsminister
die brauche man nicht mehr das habe man
eben im vergangenen jahr gemacht weil
ländlichen raum ist da eben große
probleme gegeben hätte aber diese langen
anfahrtszeiten alles andere das könnten
jetzt die hausärzte besser bewältigen
weil die der transport des impfstoffes
jetzt viel besser zu bewältigen sein
eine frage an dich und an herrn sprenger
haben habe ich das richtig verstanden
dass jetzt in diesem impfzentrum in
bochum nur ein arzt impft woran liegt so
was dass da jetzt vielleicht auch nicht
mehr personal dort ist
es ist richtig hier impft ein einziger
arzt im moment hier heute schon wir
werden auch recht schnell in der
nächsten woche wieder den ruhrcongress
das war unser im zentrum bis ende
september werden wir auch wieder
reaktivieren mit zehn im straßen die wir
dann auch anbieten die menschen kennen
diesen ort und wir haben die große
hoffnung dass wir das recht schnell
anbieten können so dass sich dann hier
auch wieder die wege entzerren ist das
denn mit dem personal finden sie
überhaupt genügend in der tat ist das
eine große herausforderung wir müssen
also jetzt sehr sehr schnell schauen
dass wir zusätzliches personal finden
wir werden natürlich auf
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter der
eigenen stadtverwaltung zurückgreifen
aber wir brauchen auch fachpersonal das
müssen wir jetzt in kürzester zeit
akquirieren und hoffen dass wir das
möglichst schnell hinbekommen dazu kommt
natürlich auch noch dass gerade das
medizinische das ärztliche personal
benötigt wird weil nur die ärzte nun
ärzte dürfen impfen
gesagt eigentlich ist es gar nicht die
sache der stadt sondern die sache der
hausärzte was für rückmeldungen erhalten
sie denn von den hausärzten aus bochum
impfen da alle also wir wissen dass es
etwa 230 niedergelassene ärztinnen und
ärzte gibt die aktuell impfen das ist
toll überhaupt keine frage und das
engagement ist wirklich auch zu loben es
gibt aber mehr als 500 niedergelassenen
ärztinnen und ärzte in dieser stadt es
gibt aber auch fachpraxen radiologen
hno-ärzte frauenärzte alle könnten
impfen insofern haben wir auch noch mal
einen dringlichen appell losgeschickt
sozusagen in die bochumer ärzteschaft
impfen sie bitte nach möglichkeit öffnen
sie ihre praxen denn nur das impfen ist
der einzige schlüssel um im moment der
pandemie herr zu werden genau mit so
einer hausärztin werden wir gleich in
dieser sendung auch noch sprechen dieses
thema werden wir hier noch behandeln was
ich jetzt noch spannend finde da bei
euch in bochum das ist ja jetzt auch
ganz besonders dass dieses kleine im
zentrum wollen wir trotzdem mal so
nennen jetzt so spät abends noch auf hat
auch die frage vielleicht wie wichtig
ist dass da jetzt auch mal bei den
öffnungszeiten abzuweichen wenn wir
diese millionen menschen schaffen wollen
bis ende des jahres
also sie haben sich ja jetzt für so eine
pragmatische lösung entschieden bis 21
uhr geöffnet ist ja eher ungewöhnlich
häufig machen jedem zehnten stellen und
17 uhr zu wie wichtig ist so was andere
zeiten vielleicht eine leichtere
erreichbarkeit ja das ist natürlich ganz
wichtig die menschen zu erreichen und
die menschen erreicht man da wo sie
daneben sind der weihnachtsmarkt ist
hier ein ganz ganz beliebter treffpunkt
in der stadt und gerade in der zeit ab
nachmittag nimmt natürlich dann hier die
frequenz enorm zu und es macht ja wenig
sinn von morgens acht bis zehn uhr hier
angebot zu machen wenn keiner da ist
sondern jetzt sind die menschen hier und
das angebot wollen wir dann eben halt
auch haben und deshalb haben wir das
sehr kurzfristig dann auch eingerichtet
aber wie gesagt der andrang der ist so
groß dass wir dann auch ab der kommenden
woche einen termin system führen müssen
weil wir können ja auch den menschen
nicht zumuten sich hier stundenlang hin
zu stellen sie hatten ja gerade das
ältere ehepaar zwei stunden das haben
wir gestern auch erlebt dass menschen
schon mehrere stunden vor der eröffnung
hier standen die hatten auch vorher
geklagt dass ihnen ganz so kalt war
vielen dank für diese ja das ist eine
politisch entschuldigung
ja
es war ja eine politische entscheidung
also der gesundheitsminister gesagt ende
september sollen die impfzentren
schließen wie haben sie das denn oder
wie sehen sie das jetzt als stadt diese
entscheidung der städtetag hat insgesamt
also das heißt alle städte haben
frühzeitig noch während die impfzentren
in betrieb waren gesagt lasst die
impfzentren auf wir wollen diese
struktur vorhalten damit die menschen
auch ein anlaufpunkt haben das war nicht
gewollt das hat der
landesgesundheitsminister daneben gegen
die empfehlung der städte trotzdem so
entschieden und dann kann man sich jetzt
nicht wundern dass die fünf zentren dann
auch tatsächlich geschlossen sind weil
es dauert eben auch man kann das nicht
auf knopfdruck wieder hochfahren es
dauert jetzt stellen zu schaffen aber
ich glaube in jeder stadt ist einfach
klar die nachfrage ist so groß wir
müssen handeln und wir handeln auch und
genau deshalb unterstützen wir auch die
ärztinnen und ärzte weil die ärzte
alleine schaffen das nicht das impfen
und deshalb stellen wir diese
zusätzlichen möglichkeiten zu verfügen
in bochum wird gehandelt vielen dank
dort ferber live nach bochum vor dem
impfzentrum vielen dank auch an thomas
sprenger der sprecher der stadt bochum
und vielen dank für die für das gespräch
und warum eine booster impfung überhaupt
so wichtig ist und ob das jetzt aber
auch eben noch öfter auch für uns
zukommt ob das jetzt uns also noch viel
länger begleiten wird als wir eigentlich
glauben dazu einen beitrag von johanna
sagt meister
schlange stehen für die booster impfung
seit gestern empfiehlt die ständige
impfkommission
auffrischungsimpfung für alle ab 18 wenn
die letzte impfung sechs monate
zurückliegt denn internationale studien
zeigen der impfschutz nimmt mit der zeit
ab schnell und effektiv wieder aufgebaut
werden kann er durch eine booster
impfung dass sie wusste brauchen
überrascht virologen nicht bei ganz
vielen impfungen benötigen wir auch
frisch impfungen wird das südlichen
zeitabständen und man muss ganz ehrlich
sagen wir fangen ja jetzt mit saas koch
2 impfung gerade erst an und ich finde
dafür hat das sehr gut funktioniert und
ich glaube uns allen war klar zumindest
aus der wissenschaftlichen seite wir
haben eigentlich auch so kommuniziert
dass wir über kurz oder lang auf
beschimpfungen brauchen von tetanus und
diphtherie bis hepatitis b gegen viele
krankheiten werden drei impfungen für
die grundimmunisierung gebraucht und
weitere als auffrischung wie viele bykow
mit 19 im laufe der jahre als
auffrischung notwendig sind weiß die
wissenschaft noch nicht es wird sich
zeigen dass es kann sein dass das
jährlich machen müssen alle drei jahre
alle zehn jahre die unterschiedlichsten
schemata kennen wir vom impfen und es
hängt auch ein bisschen vom virus ab wie
sich varianten entwickeln ob man
häufiger varianten anpassen muss bei der
jährlichen grippe impfung reagiert man
ja letztendlich auf unterschiedliche
virusvarianten und das kann uns bei saas
koch 2 ehrlich gesagt auch passieren
wenn es nach der bundesregierung geht
sondern 20 bis 25 millionen menschen bis
jahresende geburtsstadt seien für
impfzentren und arztpraxen eine mammut
aufgabe
schon jetzt stehen vielerorts die
telefone nicht mehr still
die aufgeschwungen sechs monate nach der
zweiten impfung für viele wird das nicht
klappen
das muss ist wir müssen sehr
individueller prozess also man kann der
eine wird mit diesen zwei und
immunisierungen acht monate gut
geschützt sein bei dem anderen ist es
vielleicht nach fünf monaten schon
kritisch und je jünger jemand ist je
kräftiger das immunsystem ist in der
regel wird auch etwas länger als die
sechs monate
gehen können mit der booster impfung
schützt man nicht nur sich selbst man
ist auch weniger ansteckend sie gilt als
pandemie bremse auch deshalb fordern
viele die im kapazitäten müssen jetzt
hochgefahren werden und zwar schnell
und dabei sollen auch hausärzte helfen
und genau mit so einer dürfen wird heute
sprechen mit ulrike kukksi ist
hausärztin und blockt aber auch
tatsächlich über ihren alltag als
hausärztin schönen guten abend
eine frage die jetzt viele umtreibt es
wirklich also wie lange wird uns das
jetzt begleiten ist das ganz normal dass
da jetzt immer nachgefragt aufgefrischt
werden muss bei dieser corona impfung
können sie uns das beantworten
wenn wir gerade schon beim herrn doktor
stürmer gehört dass das ein
individueller prozesses und ich glaube
auch dass wir das einfach abwarten
müssen also von vielen impfungen kennen
wir es ja dass regelmäßig aufgefrischt
werden muss gerade bei der jährlichen
grippeimpfung ist es vollkommen normal
weil das virus so wandelbar ist wie das
sich jetzt bei saas kopf 2 entwickelt
können wir jetzt noch nicht sagen ich
glaube aber dass wir uns auf jeden fall
darauf einstellen müssen dass die
booster impfung oder das was wir jetzt
als booster impfung bezeichnen im
prinzip teil der grundimmunisierung
sein wird und dann eventuell jährlich
das wird sich rausstellen wir haben dazu
auch direkt die erste frage im stream
bei youtube und zwar wie lange erweitert
der booster die immunität bzw den schutz
möchte jemand wissen
dass ich jetzt auch einen daten gelesen
hatte es gibt wohl eine studie aus
israel bei der man herausgefunden hat
dass dann wieder weitere acht monate
wohl der schutz besteht
ich glaube das muss man muss man
abwarten also ganz genaue zahlen kann
ich dazu ehrlich gesagt auch nicht sagen
aber man hat herausgefunden dass nach
drei vier monaten schon die antikörper
zurückgehen und der schutz nachlässt und
man dann mit der booster impfung
zumindest ich sage ein halbes jahr auf
jeden fall wieder schutz hat und dann
ist zumindest der winter vorbei und dann
muss man mal schauen wie sich die
pandemie weiter entwickelt und jetzt
haben jetzt gerade gesehen in bochum vor
dieser impfstelle da ist wirklich lange
schlange reger betrieb nicht für den
weihnachtsmarkt sind für die für die
impfung steht man da an und es fühlt
sich auch so ein bisschen wie ein déjà
vu als das also schon mal lange
schlangen gab wie ist denn die lage in
der praxis wo sie arbeiten zurzeit ist
da auch schon wieder richtig viel los
und andrang ja genau wie sie sagen also
das ist ein dicker wir hatten ja im
april genau diese gleiche situation
schon als wir dann angefangen haben zu
impfen und wir uns vor nachfrage kaum
retten konnten das ist jetzt eigentlich
also nicht eigentlich es ist ähnlich
weil wir jetzt auch schon wieder listen
führen in denen wir auch in gewisser
weise eine interne priorisierung machen
müssen weil wir sonst alle patienten
nicht unterkriegen wir können nicht
jetzt sofort jeden impfen so gerne wir
würden aber dafür sind die kapazitäten
nicht da und es gab viele patientinnen
die sich schon vor einigen wochen
gemeldet haben und gesagt haben es
kommen doch weil die booster impfung
wenn es die gibt bitte ich möchte ich
brauche die meine sechs monate sind
schon seit
oktober zum beispiel abgelaufenen also
auch gerade sehr viele ältere
hochbetagte menschen die sich ja schon
sehr früh haben impfen lassen
jetzt so ein bisschen meine nächste
frage von der organisation gab es für
sie jetzt schon irgendwelche infos gab
es irgendwie mal eine ansage wie sie das
jetzt eigentlich leisten sollen oder
sind sie dass wieder mehr oder weniger
auf sich selbst gestellt
man sucht sich seine infos schon
ziemlich zusammen bekommt natürlich auch
information oder rundmails von der kvb
aber in gewisser weise muss man sich
schon seine information und seine eigene
herangehensweise an die sache selbst
erarbeiten zusammen
ich glaube das macht doch jede praxis
anders
so dieses ich sag mal listen system was
wir jetzt machen weiß ich natürlich
nicht ob das jede praxis so macht wir
müssen ja unsere patienten hauptsächlich
impfen wir können auch keine von
externen zum beispiel annehmen weil es
einfach weil die nachfrage einfach zu
groß ist und die erfahrung vom april die
haben wir ja also das heißt wir wissen
wie wir vorgehen müssen es wäre
natürlich schön gewesen wenn jetzt so
ein bisschen weniger bürokratie
ja da zu erfüllen wäre das war ja schon
im april kompliziert und das hat leider
nicht nachgelassen und
jetzt denken sie darüber nach in ihrer
praxis dass vielleicht auch von den
normalen öffnungszeiten abzuweichen weil
wie soll das dann es zu schaffen sein
das machen wir durchaus also wir haben
jetzt noch vor weihnachten diverse impft
tage angelegt in denen wir nichts
anderes machen außer zu impfen also von
morgens bis weit in den nachmittag
hinein wimpfen mittwochnachmittag
freitagnachmittag das wird alles im
prinzip auch in der freizeit gemacht
beziehungsweise nach der regulären
sprechstunden weil die haben wir ja auch
wir haben hier die regelversorgung die
basisversorgung und das muss
funktionieren und nebenbei machen wir
die organisation für die impf tage für
die impftermine weil die telefone nicht
mehr still stehen und wir haben eine
infekt welle die muss also auch noch
bewerkstelligt werden und wir haben
grippe impfen
langweilig wird es gerade nicht jetzt
gibt es manche bundesländer wie bayern
da werden also die impfzentren wieder
hochgefahren da es in bochum hat man
also die impfstelle wieder reaktiviert
wie wichtig ist es für sie hausärzte und
ernsten auch dass es der entlastung gibt
beispielsweise eben wieder durch im
zentrum und impfstelle
ich finde das sehr wichtig also ich
hatte mich auch so in meiner
öffentlichkeitsarbeit immer dafür
ausgesprochen dass die impfzentren
zumindest nicht alle geschlossen werden
hier im umkreis in hessen ist es
jedenfalls so dass es doch noch einige
impfstellen gibt und so ein paar mobile
im bus herum fahren da ist vielleicht
auch einfach die
informationen darüber noch gar nicht so
durchgesickert also es gibt gar nicht so
wenige impfstellen und in busse die
immer mal
angesteuert werden können und da
verweise ich auch in der praxis gerade
die an die jüngeren und älteren
patientinnen und fr sagt okay wir würden
gerne aber bitte wenn es möglich ist ihr
seid jung und fit bitte geht da und da
hin und da könnt ihr euch eure empfohlen
allerdings habe ich da inzwischen auch
schon gehört dass da die termine auch
sehr rar werden gerade was bräuchten sie
denn jetzt damit es ein bisschen
schneller geht was bräuchten sie damit
dass jetzt für sie in der praxis besser
zu
zuzustimmen ist
also ich glaube dass wir hausärzte sehr
effektiv arbeiten können das beweisen
wir jedes jahr mit dem grippe impfungen
die 20 millionen die da jede saison
verabreicht werden das ist aber deutlich
leichter weil man nicht so ein
organisationsaufwand hat die bestellung
ist leichter man muss das den impfstoff
nicht separat aufziehen wir haben nicht
diese enorme bürokratie die da dran
hängt und ich glaube da könnte man
deutlich
verschlanken abspecken und uns damit die
arbeit erleichtern das ist vom
impfstoff her nicht funktioniert den in
einzel ampullen vielleicht zu
auszuliefern das kann ich jetzt nicht
sagen das weiß ich leider nicht aber es
ist natürlich immer so der
bestellprozess hängt damit dran die
aufklärung dass ein bestellen dann
müssen wir natürlich immer und so ich
sage meinen patienten bündeln bestellen
weil wenn wir eine ampulle bestellen
dann müssen wir sechs sieben patienten
dafür haben also das muss alles
berücksichtigt werden das ganze dann zu
melden abzurechnen insgesamt ist es
extrem viel aufwand aber genug impfstoff
gibt es jetzt anders als im frühling
schon also dieses chaos das bleibt uns
erspart oder bis jetzt sieht so aus als
wir hatten jetzt keine probleme bei der
bestellung okay ich will mal hier in die
kommentare und statements gucken es geht
vor allem auch einige statements jetzt
gerade zu den auffrischungsimpfungen zum
beispiel schreibt matthias gottschalk
bei facebook booster wird natürlich
gemacht schon weil mein vater ein
pflegefall ist da ist also jemand ganz
klar dafür hat es also vielleicht sogar
schon gemacht oder vor karin van bergen
schreibt bei facebook brauchen impfungen
tekken von geschultem personal das wird
auch noch mal eine frage die ich gerne
an sie richten würde würde so was sie im
zweifel auch entlassen weil es gibt ja
die diskussion dass also
pflegefachpersonal jetzt auch vielleicht
impfen sollte oder in apotheken
die diskussion die gab es ja schon
jährlich bei der grippeimpfung und
ich denke jetzt gerade eben der pandemie
sollte man auch mal andere wege gehen
und über so etwas nachdenken dass man
wirklich alle stellen einbindet und
alles fach und alles personal was ja
impfen könnte
glaube schon dass wir jetzt um irgendwie
diese 25 millionen impfungen oder ich
glaube herr spahn sprach auch von 40
millionen impfungen bis weihnachten zu
verabreichen braucht man definitiv
unterstützung sie hatten zuvor auch
immer wieder sie bloggen ja eben auch
über ihren alltag als ärztin und gerade
jetzt natürlich auch in der korona zeit
und sie hatten zuvor in einem ihrer
blogeinträge vor dem bund länder treffen
die 2g konnten also die 2g konsequenz
ziemlich klar gefordert sind sie denn
jetzt damit zufrieden dass das also
jetzt gekommen ist gekoppelt an eben die
hospitalisierung rate dass da also auch
zweig eingeführt werden kann finden sie
das gut
ja in anbetracht der tatsache dass diese
pandemie irgendwie beenden müssen finde
ich finde ich das gut
was ich mir vielleicht noch mehr
gewünscht hätte wär ein
länderübergreifendes vorgehen weil
eine eine pandemie hält sich nicht an
grenzen ein virus hält sich nicht an
grenzen und wenn das einfach auf die
verschiedenen bundesländer übertragen
wird diese entscheidung dann
wird ein land diese maßnahmen ergreifen
das andere bundesland wieder nicht und
ich glaube dass dieser flickenteppich an
maßnahmen dazu kompliziertes und wir ein
einheitliches vorgehen bräuchten ja es
gibt tatsächlich unterschiedlichkeiten
also jetzt bayern beispielsweise da sind
die zahlen aber eben auch sehr hoch die
korona zahlen also bayern hat er jetzt
im strengere maßnahmen auch eingeführt
es gibt auch ein kommentar bei youtube
com schreibt österreich unser
nachbarland führt die allgemeine
impfpflicht ein richtig so söder zieht
nach und trägt das auch an die
gesellschaft kommt dann nicht mehr
vorbei sonst geht das im april mit fünf
tabelle weiter findet rom bei youtube da
noch mal ein statement es gibt aber auch
einige fragen sehr gezielt auch noch an
sie jetzt im bezug auf die impfung und
zwar möchte ich da auch noch mal eine
aufgreifen und zwar möchte
arminius nix schwieriger name bei
youtube wissen wäre es ratsam bei
doppelt astra bereits nach fünf monaten
aufzufrischen
ja
klare antwort ja
wenn sie gerne noch weiter aus also
man hat ja auch in studien gesehen dass
gerade auch noch zweimal astra die
antikörper ein bisschen schneller wieder
zurückgehen als bei 2 x bionic am besten
hat moderner da wohl abgeschnitten aber
nach zweimal astra wenn man einen termin
bekommt würde ich tatsächlich
schon nach fünf monaten auf frischen
also ich hoffe sowieso dass man ein
bisschen davon ab kommt da sich genau an
diese sechs monate zu halten mein mann
hat ja inzwischen schon gesagt so ab
ungefähr fünf bis sechs monate wie ich
aber immer wieder gelesen hat ist es
eben auch so dass in vielen impfstellen
patientinnen oder impflinge tatsächlich
weggeschickt wurden weil zwei tage
gefehlt haben oder zwei wochen gefehlt
haben ich denke so etwas darf nicht
passieren weil wir jede booster impfung
benötigen und wenn sich jemand auf den
weg gemacht hat und freut dass er jetzt
sein auffrischung kriegt dann ist das
eigentlich fatale ein fatales signal
jetzt geht es und gibt es natürlich da
jetzt auch viele menschen die sich für
die booster impfung interessieren aber
wie ist das jetzt eigentlich seit
gestern also seit die bund länder
maßnahmen verkündet wurden haben sie
dabei sich in der praxis jetzt auch mehr
menschen erlebt die eben noch nicht
geimpft sind und jetzt vielleicht
sondern impfung kommen möchten
also von gestern bis heute habe ich da
ehrlich gesagt keine großen
veränderungen festgestellt ich denke das
werden wir nächste woche erst erfahren
wie da der wunsch nach erste oder zweite
impfung ist
tatsächlich ist es so aber dass wir in
der praxis aktuell keine erstimpfungen
machen sondern zweit impfungen und puste
impfungen weil die organisation von den
nachfolge terminen spricht dann zweit
und dritt das ist aktuell nicht zu
schaffen
ja das ist natürlich das große problem
die organisation ich lese nur in den
kommentaren von euch gibt es gar nicht
so viele fragen in richtung
organisationen sondern noch mal sehr
gezielt auch auf die impfung an sich
vielleicht darf ich da trotzdem nochmal
eine auch rauspicken und zwar fragt sich
hier roland schmitz justen bei facebook
welches impfschema gilt für corona
erkrankte die nach ihrer genesung einmal
geimpft sind
also wer nach wehr wir corona hatte der
ist ja hat er für sechs monate einen
genesenen schein und muss sich dann
sozusagen impfen lassen und dann wäre
man ja auch erst mal für
sechs monate sozusagen wieder geschützt
also da müsste man jetzt noch nicht
direkt nach impfen
und auch noch eine weitere ziemlich
konkrete frage gezielt auf den impfstoff
an sich also gerne und albrecht bei
facebook fragt ist der impfstoff für die
aktuelle delta variante denn geändert
worden
nein nein das ist nicht geändert worden
also das ist nach wie vor der
ursprüngliche
impfstoff also sowohl bei tag als auch
bei moderner
mann hat allerdings jetzt eben
rausgefunden dass die büste rung einfach
nochmal einen deutlichen deutlich
besseren schutz gegenüber der delta
variante bietet ich bei der booster
impfung sind wir dann bei ungefähr 96
prozent
für einen schweren verlauf aber es gibt
jetzt aktuell noch keinen neuen
impfstoff
und jetzt wird es natürlich bei ihnen
aber jetzt erstmal ganz stark auch vor
allem um die booster impfung gehen das
haben jetzt schon mitgekriegt dass das
auch was ist was halt viele leute schon
interessiert wie blicken sie da jetzt
wirklich auf die nächsten wochen bis
weihnachten was ist also ihre prognose
was ihre praxis dazu erwarten hat
wir werden viel kaffee brauchten
also es wird wirklich so sein dass wir
extrem viel zu tun haben werden dass wir
separate impft tage machen wir brauchen
glaube ich viel
wir brauchen ein dickes fell weil wir ja
zum teil auch
ja mit ungeduldigen und zum teil auch
manchmal nicht so freundlichen anrufen
zu tun haben weil wir das ganze
eben anders handhaben müssen als das
vielleicht die politik vorgibt oder wir
das auch einfach so nicht leisten können
wir müssen parallel die infect welle und
die basisversorgung leisten also das
wird zumindest bis weihnachten extrem
anstrengend und ich glaube nicht dass es
danach deutlich leichter wird also ich
sag mal bis zum frühjahr haben wir viel
zu tun
vielen dank frau rieke cook wir wünschen
ihnen da jetzt viel kraft für die
nächsten wochen die vielen dank dass sie
sich heute abend extra zeit genommen
haben ich danke und für alle die jetzt
noch ganz gezielt auch noch fragen zu
dem impfstoff zu impfstoffen und zum
impfen an sich haben wir haben gestern
war es gestern mein gott jeder tag war
ein cooler tag auf jeden fall gibt es
ein spannendes video hier bei uns bei
youtube mit frau professor protzer da
könnt ihr auch noch mal in alle fragen
nachschauen für heute abend und für eure
aufmerksamkeit und die ganzen fragen und
kommentare jetzt erstmal vielen dank und
bis dahin tschüss